If you ever look into Mike from PA, he uh you're doxing him right
now. You just said his location. I'm sorry. I saw Lance from
the surfs today because you just said that. I remember he is
so stupid. You commentary viewers don't realize that Ethan Klein
is using you because you're going to get hit the same way. It's
like no, I actually react to the video. I don't pull up for my
lunch break. I think I'll be okay.
Lance
may be the dumbest that there is. It it he's still some say he's
still looking for those mass graves. Uh oh Jesus. You really
went you took it up a step there. I was just I was just being
mean and you were you were like hold on Dan. Let's get let's
get you on some sort of subre
debate to Lauren Southern the same week he lost a a [__]
communist versus capitalist debate to JF Gipe. And JF was probably
plotting the death of his wife while it was happening. Hypothetically
of course.
or JF, you